the baby's apologizing yeah he's
apologizing the baby's bending over
the baby is bending over you know what's
really funny though this is what i don't
understand like why [ __ ] won't
just apologize it's like
you lie to secure the bag like if you're
if let's say you
come from a world where you're a hustler
right you lie to secure the bag the cops
go yo you selling drugs you go no
you don't stand on it yes i'm a drug
dealer i'm a drug salesman i sell drugs
to make tons of money ten toes down
exactly you lie to secure the bag right
so the reason why he got [ __ ] up is
because he doubled down if he said that
[ __ ] and then came out immediately he
was just like
yo i was just trying to hype up the
audience i said some dumb [ __ ] like now
that you guys pointed out it's
absolutely ridiculous
my bad i [ __ ] up yeah i was drunk on
stage or some [ __ ] i was drunk like i
was getting charged up i literally just
wanted them to bring their lights up i
don't know what the [ __ ] i was saying
like
i was just trying to say things i
thought people would absolutely agree
with so they put the lights on
and we could really charge up the show
but thank you guys for pointing me out
that [ __ ] was stupid
let me go back to making my music right
if you said that nobody gives a flying
[ __ ] about it
right but because it became a thing
where you get to showcase your support
for a specific community that is
pressed everybody and their mother got
to come out the woodwork for it yeah
right
and then once the people come out the
world work once el and john madonna and
all these people start commenting
the the organizations that are putting
on these festivals they have to take you
off
because if you don't condemn you support
in the eyes of the public
right and even if you don't support
please believe
ellen john madonna and these other
[ __ ] that are trying to get
some clout off the situation
are gonna come out and go uh hey why are
you supporting this person who's
homophobic yeah
and if they don't say something the gays
that have supported them for so long
are gonna come at them and go so we
support you and then you're just silent
when we need you the most so like
everybody is fighting for their own
reputation
or fighting for clout right yeah because
i could see multiple artists at
lollapalooza being like oh i'm not gonna
associate
because of whatever whatever and then
they lose five artists like maybe
gay artists that are performing they're
like yeah i don't wanna be on the same
stage so they gotta protect themselves
from losing the artist we lose one or
lose five yeah well and i don't even
think they're worried about the artist
but that is a good point i just think
they're worried about reputation
well that's what i mean like i mean the
money for the festival also their
reputation but like yeah i
literally just think it's reputation
because right people are still gonna go
to the festival no one's selling tickets
they hype like everybody's ready to be
out there and get
deltaed they're out there ready for that
delta right we've been seeing all these
festivals go crazy number spike and
nobody gives a [ __ ] there's nobody
afraid of toronto no more let's go
but they don't want the smoke they don't
want to be known as and once one
festival cancels
if you don't cancel him now
right so lollapalooza said nah
governor's ball just said
nah right and now the governor's ball
said not the baby realize how many
millions of dollars he's going to end up
losing because of this because it's not
just this it's your european tours it's
all the tours around the world that you
were going to be in and this
[ __ ] doubled down
that's the dumbest [ __ ] he kept doubling
down i'm going to be an icon i'm going
to be a star
sometimes i got to know you're going to
be apologizing that's what you're going
to do and the issue is the double down
was worse
i think probably worse than what he said
initially why yeah
i don't know because the double down was
like because initially he says like if
you don't have hiv aids or something
that kills you in three weeks put your
lighter up and it's like that's
insensitive blah blah i get it
yeah but then he comes back and says no
my gay fans
are not nasty they don't have hiv aids
or whatever yeah and so like he puts gas
on the hiv thing yeah
while like also separating like the gay
community which like
if you're already offended by what he
said and you're in the gay community
like
what he said was more offensive to you
and then he said y'all do you i'ma do me
yeah
yeah very much i don't care if
get ready yeah so he literally put the
gas on them
yeah right he charged him up yeah he
could have said nothing
but he basically said i dare you yeah
and they took that [ __ ] dare yeah
and i think he underestimated like the
influence
yeah maybe i mean i think when you're at
that level you understand
your influence you're like i think you
understand influence
he misunderstood like gay influences he
overestimated the baby yeah yeah
he thought that [ __ ] was the guy
leading the world
right like i understand when you're
built in that ecosystem the only people
around you the people
either kissing your ass or the people
screaming your name because how famous
you are you start to think holy [ __ ] i'm
the president
i can say whatever the [ __ ] i want to
say what they gonna do right you know i
think he put out a video like
i don't know if it was the next day or
something they already had filmed
but like he had like a sign in the video
i think yeah
yeah they had like aids on the [ __ ]
side so it looks like he was trolling
yeah it was probably an older video i
don't think so no he said
i think he had a pose and said like he
filmed that video then flew straight to
uh rolling loud then performed and he
had the video and no one was going to be
a controversy or something which i don't
think
or he could have edited something onto
the picture like it might have been a
film before edit it after cause he's
like yeah let's put gas on it like make
a moment
maybe i mean i don't know i just think i
think it's just so funny to see these
things happen
and also there's the hypocrisy of these
festivals right
yeah and they're aware of their own
hypocrisy they're in a situation
where there's nothing they could do
that's going to be consistent yeah
they're valueless they're
moralists right and they have to be
yes right if they say nothing they're
absolutely trashed by the artist
like what mark was saying artists could
start saying i don't want to be at la
palooza if you're not going to protect
the lgbt community right but at the same
time
if they do take the baby off then we're
going to go through every lyric of all
the other people that are there and
surely if we have some hip-hop dudes at
this festival
there's going to be some f-bombs thrown
yeah yeah i mean i think
i don't want to be snitching on these
artists so i'm not going to do it but
like it ain't hard to snitch the
[ __ ] said it and their [ __ ]
right tons of them the people that are
performing at those very shows
have tons of homophobic lyrics old matt
damon stuff just flying out
but and that's just the homophobia you
want to talk about other morally
bankrupt [ __ ] that they're saying
they're gonna have it in there which is
interesting because i started to see
that comment i've you've made it a lot
of times but i started to see that
comment
in like the comments on the baby like
the lyrics of half of these guys are
about murder and god knows what else
and now you have a problem with what he
says you don't have a problem with his
own song which is a point again you've
been making for a while but this time i
started to see that in the comments from
like i started to see that voice get
louder and i think what i'm realizing
about like uh
hip-hop i think that most people do this
already with hip-hop so we don't need to
create this caveat we have to create a
comedy but hip-hop usually you get to
say whatever you want with impunity but
like
i think what the thing with hip-hop is
and the difference between comedy is
comedy's like
hey we don't really believe these things
we're saying jokes and these are
playing off of like feelings that we
have but that we control
in normal society and we don't act on
these feelings they're essentially all
lies
but they tap into a feeling of truth
take my wife please
you don't want someone to take your wife
but sometimes you're like man get this
woman away from me
this is all borschbell comedy right and
that still exists today with all these
feelings right
um so i think with hip-hop is
the rapper so yo this is my life i was
really out here doing this [ __ ]
killing people selling drugs they
weren't most of them right maybe they
were associated or kind of close or
something like that
that being said like all of us got a
little tony montana in them
in us deep down we don't want to be a
drug kingpin but we see the life we're
like
be kind of cool to be a drug kingpin
yeah you know so there's a mafia
documentary on
netflix that just came out it's so fire
and i'm so like yeah that looks so mafia
that looks amazing that's so cool right
in reality i don't want to kill people
for no reason exactly what is [ __ ]
interesting
threw it in the yes and i think all of
us get to tap into that
so when these lyrics are said i don't
think we're living vicariously through
homophobia
but the morally bankrupt [ __ ] like
murder and drug dealing and stuff like
that there's something sexy about it
because of film and television all these
years
what a dangerous lifestyle it is right
some people might feel the same way
about being a [ __ ] biker gang or
something like that
so i understand like why we want to live
that way and why
for whatever reason it's more acceptable
yeah i think the reason why it gets
tricky with rap is because they're like
nah that's really me i lived it
if they were really like i'm kind of
like a theater kid yeah yeah that's a
little tekker thing
that's look go go a little too tech is
his rapper and like he just said over
and over like he's all these like lyrics
like
i make you dance with my glock like [ __ ]
like that and then they go
do you have guns he goes i've never
owned a gun i've never shot a gun it's
like i've grew up in the suburbs i'm not
in a gang i just like to rap crazy [ __ ]
cause it's fun
yeah he's like 18 year old kid and like
his music's great yeah it's like us with
jokes like we just
make these we have these crazy feelings
or a crazy perspective about a topic
we're like let's go let's make something
funny and we elicit laughter with these
ideas because they are so absurd they
are so crazy so
maybe one day we'll be able to treat rap
in the same way homophobia is different
because i don't think we're like tapping
into like
our like hatred right you know what i
mean regardless of what robin d'angelo
says that [ __ ] bozo
the bozo of a lady that lady yeah i
don't even know who she is
yeah you shouldn't yeah i feel like i'm
happier that way yeah
probably smarter too i wish i never was
on twitter that day just just
stupid [ __ ] crusty nancy pelosi mouth
about comedy just go back to writing
books you [ __ ] dork [ __ ]
anyway so uh she's just the lady was
like comedy is inherently racist
super famous she was the woman like
she's a white woman of course she's a
white woman yeah of course i don't want
to hear any white woman's opinion on
racism
ever you know she's white can't assault
like you know there always will be a
place on the internet for uh
a black person to tell white people that
are not racist yeah they have done
anything wrong
there will always be a place on the
internet for a white person to tell
minorities
you're monetizing white guilt just in a
different way in a different way yeah
there's like i feel guilty that like i
grew up in a racist place tell me that
i'm not racist exactly
i respect candace owens more because she
gotta stand in fire
her people are coming at her [ __ ]
neck yeah agree or disagree she stands
in a fire yeah this [ __ ] is
removing herself from the fire even
totally goofy i don't know she probably
gets crazy death threats and [ __ ] like
she probably has her own [ __ ] i'm like
yeah i wouldn't want to be on the fringe
either way trying to monetize people's
guilt
yeah it's just a it's a weird way to
make her gross dude cancel her
cancel her take her out of barnes noble
or wherever the [ __ ]
she wants to be the issue with the baby
thing to me is that i mean obviously he
said
[ __ ] that's crazy but he like when you
attach it to
like hiv and aids it's like so much more
visceral yeah
like if you're saying like like i don't
know there's all these lyrics that
people are pulling up from rappers and
[ __ ] being like oh i don't [ __ ] with gay
[ __ ] yeah but when you are saying like
when you're putting this like visceral
attachment to things that like people
died from that
i don't know it makes it a different
association in your head i think if he
just said the parking lot thing he'd be
fine
mark i'll be completely honest with you
and this goes back to the chris drock
joke if he said that in a song he's fine
yeah even hiv even the hiv no matter
what you say
if it's in a song it's totally fine
because what happens is in a song we
could tap into the joke thing hey this
is just a joke it's just a piece of art
i'm living vicariously through it it's
like okay these guys are
and it's it's fine it's kind of [ __ ]
up it's like the bigotry of low
expectations you guys have heard that
but like
i really think there's a lot of people
that are just like it's okay if rappers
are homophobic because they don't know
better
they're from circumstances where they
don't know better it's like you're
actually holding them to a lower
standard it's kind of [ __ ] up but
uh but that being said like if it was in
a song
you'd be able to chalk it up to oh it's
just rhyming a moment and taking this
passionate thing and blah blah blah
but the fact that there wasn't any beat
going it's like you being a person
it's the difference like we always say
it's like if if the racists are
homophobic or bigoted thing you say
is the joke it's okay you're not gonna
cancel something for the joke but if you
say it as you're walking down the street
and someone cuts you off
you can't go oh yeah this is a joke so
it felt like he wanted that he felt like
he really felt that way and then when
you double down on it it's like you
dummy
yeah you dummy all you have to do is say
you're sorry and you don't lose millions
of dollars
that's also a place where having a hype
man is really not helpful because they
get gassed
right the hype man's like yo y'all
looking such as a [ __ ] right
yeah yeah it's like
all right i didn't mean to say that
don't hype that part hype it in the
other way be like he didn't mean it
you